Peter Parker is getting some slick new duds
in Spider-Man's second solo outing in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe.
In December 2018, Brazil's Comic Con Experience
played host to a splashy rollout for the Homecoming
follow-up.
One of the most exciting surprises was a new
black Spider-suit, built for stealth, which
we'll get to see in action when Spider-Man:
Far From Home sees release in July 2019.
This won't be the first time we've gotten
to see Peter Parker rock an upgraded outfit
in the MCU.
In Spider-Man: Homecoming, the first standalone
feature for Tom Holland's version of the wall-crawler,
the burgeoning hero initially wore a low-fi
homemade suit before slipping into the high-tech
outfit Tony Stark designed for him.
At the time, that suit was the most technologically-advanced
outfit we'd ever seen Spider-Man wear onscreen,
with flash and flair and an AI assistant to
rival Iron Man's armor.
"Hey suit lady, I kind of feel bad calling
you suit lady, you know?
I think I should probably give you a name."
But while Tony Stark played a big part in
Spider-Man: Homecoming, it doesn't look as
though the character will be appearing at
all in Far From Home.
The absence of Iron Man has led some fans
to conclude that Avengers: Endgame will mark
Mr. Stark's swan song, but we're not too sure
about that yet.
A lot needs to be explained in the MCU's story
between now and Far From Home's release, like
how exactly Peter is going to be coming back
to life.
To be honest, this whole movie should come
with a spoiler alert.
Instead of an assist from Stark Industries,
it looks like Far From Home will instead feature
Peter getting some help from former S.H.I.E.L.D.
agents Maria Hill and Nick Fury, and considering
their super-spy bona fides, they may well
have had a hand in getting Peter his sleek
new stealth suit.
In stark contrast to the ultra-high-tech Iron
Spider suit featured in Avengers: Infinity
War, the stealth suit features a decidedly
more low-tech aesthetic.
Blurry photos of the new suit have been circulating
around the internet since Far From Home started
filming, but now we've got the first official
look at the new duds.
The photo shows Spider-Man star Tom Holland
suited up in the sleek costume, perched on
what looks like the edge of a window.
The new black suit has almost no resemblance
to the classic black symbiote suit, and it's
also much more low-tech than the stealth suit
from the Spider-Man PS4 game.
This take on the stealth suit looks to be
composed of a fine mesh underlayer, with several
tactical accessories.
There's a flak jacket-like chest piece, complete
with a visible zipper, and eyepieces in the
classic Spidey shape.
It also features thigh pads, shin-high boots,
fingerless gloves, and spiffy black web-shooters.
In an interesting turnaround from the Iron
Spider suit, this getup actually looks like
something a well-funded teenager could put
together for themselves, which should be a
boon for hopeful cosplay enthusiasts.
Beyond the new black super suit, we don't
know a great deal about what's going to go
down in Far From Home.
We know that a great deal of the story will
be taking place in Europe, far away from Spidey's
typical haunts of Queens and Manhattan, hence
the title.
And we also know that Jake Gyllenhaal will
be taking on the young Avenger as the nefarious
trickster villain Mysterio.
But beyond those broad ideas, very few actual
plot details have emerged about the movie,
meaning that it isn't clear what kind of sneaky
missions might necessitate the new threads.
Will Spider-Man be sneaking into some secret
facility?
Or will he be slinging himself around European
vistas while in hiding from his enemies?
For now, it's up in the air.
While we don't know what the suit will be
for, exactly, the inspiration for the suit's
design seems clear.
The stealth suit bears more than a passing
resemblance to the outfit worn by a character
named Spider-Man Noir, an alternate universe
version of Spider-Man who's appeared in both
the comic books and the Sony animated feature
Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse.
But enough about the new black suit, what's
going on with Peter's default outfit?
In October 2018, Tom Holland showed off a
revamped version of his classic Homecoming
suit during an appearance on Jimmy Kimmel
Live.
It's a fairly simple redesign, swapping out
the blue portions of the original suit for
black.
The stealth version, on the other hand, is
like nothing we've ever seen Spidey wear onscreen
before, even the black symbiote suit from
Sam Raimi's Spider-Man 3.
But while Spider-Man's outfit is going dark
again, we're pretty sure he'll be keeping
his sunny personality this time around.
A dark and gritty Spider-Man?
That sounds like the last thing audiences
want.
"Activating instant kill."
"Oh no-no-no-no-no I don't wanna kill anybody."